that's not the plan
um I saw you had recently you got a BBL
right yeah was this in uh America would
you go to teach it no I went to TJ
the second time you've doubled up on the
BBL well I had the first one was uh
yeah every time I got a kid I got a
certain
uh I go to the dentist every time
because I don't have I don't have health
insurance because I'm an independent
contractor so when I go to get dental
work done I go to Tijuana amazing
amazing doctors they're great and I the
first time I went to Beverly Hills the
second time after Journey our daughter
ordered the money yeah after after our
daughter is he covering the cost on the
BBL yeah I'm not of course no the first
you better pay for this bro the first
time she went to Beverly Hills she was
like they won 30 000 I said for what
she said just to take the fat out of my
stomach and put it in my ass I said
[Music]
but I didn't know
I didn't know TJ in there
just like I think if you
think yeah it's gonna be overrated
they're hitting you upside the head
because they're gonna be like well Kylie
was here and yeah it's like go to
Arizona so I didn't agree with it but I
was like you know what for you [__] it
if it'll make you feel better about
yourself [__] 30 000 do it 100 so the
second time we had another baby she was
like you know I found a better a place
where they could take out more fat right
and do more better Banks per book right
and I got a tummy tuck Anna bibio that
was probably about a month ago she's
still here no I it was like two months
uh I got it in May yeah so it's been
like two months the bbo essentially is I
don't understand what the tummy tuck is
right because that's kind of like um
it's kind of like if you have kids if
you have and you have that pouches just
never goes
never go away because it's fast so the
second time she got it at the arms at
the stomach and then they put it in your
cheeks she didn't even in my hips well
no my hips not my ass I just got in my
hips uh I just got I just got my hips
because I just wasn't trying to be OD
like right I don't really that's not my
goal is to be hey you know it's funny
online if it looks a certain type of way
but you're live in person stand up no
stand up let's give let's get ready
listen to TJ TJ they try to say the legs
don't match you know look all right can
we see what the tattoo looks like got
the Jonathan Porter tattoo where is it
is it how I don't I mean I don't want
you to like expose yourself oh there it
is oh yeah that's OG tat right there
that thing looks like it was done in
prison
yeah
because I said I I think you'll you'll
see some bbls and they're they look
terrible right this this looks solid
yeah good I mean shout out to Mexico
right it's a good place definitely it
looks a lot a lot more like
it looks a lot more ratio ratio for sure
online sometimes they do they do find
where the angles to where I be like damn
they don't even look like that's why I
say like oh it don't even talk about
like diaper and all this weird [__] why
isn't that you Jaden like you
some listen there is a certain aspect of
the internet that rides hard for
Christian and automatically oh yeah so I
don't really care yeah it's like a pick
a side thing so pick a side then so
myself
I mean like pick a side I don't give a
[__] because to me I'm not in a
competition I'm in my own thing no
traffic there ain't no traffic if you're
in your own lane you feel me so it's
kind of like I don't give a [__] so if
that's if you want to side with that
side with that because you already know
if my [__] play in the club we going up
well I'm just curious like
I'm sure people like like you said like
we've seen memes about the drusky thing
and it's funny that's great well I think
it's so viral that you take it that way
because I think
we are in an aspect where everyone's
gonna come at you on the internet yeah
regardless I mean at first obviously it
was kind of like how do you deal with it
is it hard at first it was kind of like
ew like what do you mean like um stewing
I'm drifting on this I'm that like ew
right but but I think that I don't I
don't like come on now the thing is is
like I think with anything especially
like internet driven because again this
guy's a goat on the internet he is so
much so okay can we shut your guys door
who sounds like he's in there having a
podcast shut the [__] up
we recorded tiny
shut the [__] up
she sounds like he's in there cussing
someone sound like you having a podcast
[__]
foreign